all right Brendan
Brendan where'd you grow up where are
you from originally I grew up in
Beaumont Texas
it's about 1600 miles away from here
I lived there my whole life until I was
about 25 years old
um small town considerably mostly blacks
I wasn't around a lot of white people I
grew up in a very very slow neighborhood
very ghetto popularized me and my five
siblings
have a twin brother his name is Blake
and all my other siblings are from the
same mom and dad
came Erica Josh me Blake
I grew up there and I never really went
outside of there I stayed in that City
for the most part
um I came here at the age of 25. how
would you describe your childhood
very rough
very rough we were always so starving
for food we always were on EBT or
food stamps and my mom struggles really
hard working at a job that wasn't paying
anything she was just working at a Dairy
Queen trying to make ends meet and my
dad was lazy bastard and he didn't want
to get up and get out of bed and he
didn't want to work for nothing he
expected hands out handouts his whole
life and
it wasn't really worth it
he left at the age of 11 for me
and he left because he ended up being
gay
so at that young age I didn't know how
to really take it too well
shortly after he had left my mom had got
another boyfriend and his his name is
Troy Watts he's my stepfather now
and if it wasn't for him I wouldn't know
where I'd be right now I'd be a lot
worse than I am now honestly
um my dad didn't want anything to do
with me really for the most part
throughout my teenage years
I didn't link back up with them until
about the age of 21.
and then around then I started to kind
of like take an effect like yeah my
dad's gay I have to deal with this this
is his choice
let it be just you know let bygones be
bygones so I decided to be
for the longest time I didn't know how
it was going to take or react to people
being gay or what I should
what I should even do like
considering the fact that basically half
my siblings are either gay or half the
other same thing that's straight
so I guess they can around age 12
I started using drugs like marijuana
cigarettes any kind of pills I could get
my hands on
my mom was always in and out of the
doctors for surgeries so she always got
pain pills and I would always take them
I'd ended up stealing lots of lots of
her pills throughout my teenage years
and eventually they had to lock the door
on me
they would go out to eat
sure enough when they would come back
they'd be wiped clean because I would
have done broken in my mom's room and
just telling all over meds and
shortly after that from the age of 12 to
15 I picked up an opioid addiction that
I didn't realize was happening to me
and really after my own personal surgery
I ended up getting circumcised at the
age of 13.
and due to that they prescribed me
Vicodin which was the starting point to
jump off for me in opiates and I didn't
know at the time like I do now that I
was slowly but surely getting a due to
opiates whether I liked it or not
and in fact I did like I liked the way
they made me feel
couldn't help it
so by the age of 17 18 I started taking
a considerably a large amount of
painkillers
20 to 30 Tramadol with 20 to 30 Vicodin
or lower tabs a day
at the age 18 I found out how to shoot
up
and I started shooting up Dilaudid
Oxycontin
um I hadn't done meth yet at that age
surprisingly I didn't start doing
methamphetamine so I was 23.
um when meth entered my life it
basically gave me like an outing to be
able to do stuff that I normally
couldn't do when I was on opiates
because I'd be just so high I couldn't
function basically
and I started doing myth a lot more
smoking and snorting it any way possible
eating it you know you name it
um
from the age of 24 till now I have been
shooting up methamphetamine and Fentanyl
together every day for about three years
now
I can't function without it sadly I get
very very sick physically not just
mentally
um it's about a hundred and fifty dollar
a day have it
I somehow managed to make that much
money and still be able to get food and
clothes and all the other necessities
that you need to have to be able to live
you know
um
it's just it's an addiction so it's so
hard to stop
how do you make money
Panhandle I ask people if I could borrow
money from here and there I get my GR
um any kind of way really it doesn't
matter like I'll do basically anything
besides like sexual favors for like you
know men or anything like that I won't
do that what uh what do you say I stay
here on the streets I stay at MacArthur
Park
events or something like that I know I
don't even have a tent right now I'm
literally just like drifting from place
to place on the streets
your drug addiction started at what age
12 12. and you're how old now 28.
you have a twin brother yes is he in a
similar situation no he's in a
completely opposite situation he has a
great job a beautiful apartment
a beautiful girlfriend
he's doing very well for himself
considerably he has cerebral palsy and
Kiara syndrome
so he has to fight with that battle
every day of his life
that that alone was enough for him to
realize like hey he knew what he wanted
early on in life before we even
graduated high school I think he knew
we grew further and further apart from
one another I barely even talked to him
now
your friends
yeah
I have friends from all over every place
I've been so far throughout the United
States I've made friends
come and go but you know a lot of my
friends too have died from drug overdose
who here recently
um I've saved 53 people I saved
somebody's life this morning actually
they were overdosing right there at the
park on the top of the train station
nobody wanted to do anything for this
man and I walked by
and everybody just scattered away from
I could see that it was overdosing so we
hit him with two narcans up the nasal
boom boom
and I guess slowly feel his breathing
starting to come back because he was
blue
Blues can get and I can feel his
breathing come back so I dug my Knuckles
into the side of his ribs
to help him kind of set him into a shock
therapy to give
get them keep them keep them alive keep
them breathing keep them coherent and
eventually about 15 minutes past and he
took that one last gasp of air that I
needed to hear and he came to and when
his eyes blinked he looked at me and
said who are you
I said that doesn't matter man
you're alive right now
just be thankful that you're alive and
breathing right now
[Music]
what emotions do you go through living
this life
very depressing emotions I get impressed
very easily high anxiety
everything is so so real to me and I
take everything in very much so it was
like a hundred percent
I do wear my heart on my sleeve
I'm very much so like in 50 wise I I
feel a lot of empathy for a lot of
people I do try to help out as much as I
can
but sometimes it just doesn't seem like
it's enough you know
right now I have a girlfriend being
homeless which is surprising because
apparently homeless people don't get
girlfriends or boyfriends you know
you're on your own usually
luckily I have a girlfriend right now
that actually cares about me
she makes sure that I'm well first
before even herself
I couldn't be more happy and thankful
for a person like that
what are you afraid of what do you worry
about
I'm afraid of my own life getting taken
due to the situations I get myself into
sometimes
situations that I don't realize at the
moment that are going to be very
traumatic in the end result or could
somehow potentially harm me or kill me
just recently I was smashed over the top
of my head
with a lead pipe about a week and a half
ago just because I got into an argument
with my girlfriend and somebody had seen
it and they took it the wrong way
completely and they then proceeded to
smash me over the head with a lead
python I bled out quite a bit my whole
tint that I had was full blood I ended
up having to throw it away
munch my clothes
it took about two hours of bleeding and
stop then it finally stopped luckily for
me I wasn't knocked out or unconscious
or anything like that I was still
coherent I was in shock quite a bit
though because of the loss of blood I'd
never seen that much blood come from my
own body so it did Scare Me
but in the end result I didn't need to
go to the hospital all I had was a minor
concussion I didn't have to get stitches
it barely nicked me on the top of my
head but that little Nick they say
is not what I felt I felt a huge gash
but luckily it was just a little skin
Nick somehow I guess I have a strong
head strong body
and you know everything was okay after
like
two days after it held up everything was
good it scapped over
I washed everything and cleaned
everything out
but I now know not to even think about
trying to get into an argument in public
with my girlfriend because you never
know what could happen
do you feel helpless against your
addiction
yes
you tried to quit I tried I've gotten
clean before I was clean for almost two
and a half years and
it literally can be any little thing
that you see or hear that can set you
back into the Motions of addiction it
doesn't matter what it is if it has
anything to do with with it or relate to
it in some way or another it can totally
set you into a downward spiral Spiral
and
you're not going to know what to do
but the one thing that you do know and
let's go back to drugs
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
I would have never taken those pills
that's a such a young age
I would have thrown them away
that would have definitely been a good
thing
I wouldn't be here talking to you though
so
who's your best your favorite memory
from your childhood
learning how to skateboarding
learning an escape wood for sure that or
probably seeing my twin brother walk
when doctors told him that he was never
going to be able to walk
I took the stroller The Walker out of
his hand and pushed it down and I told
my little brother you're going to walk
dude
just because they say you can't doesn't
mean you're not going to be able to sure
enough I remember the day that I did
throw the stroller down out of his hands
and I made him get up and walk
and he walked Walked for me we're about
five years old
I've been in love before yeah
um my previous ex Robin she was actually
my wife of seven years
we're still technically married on paper
um we both struggle with addiction her
so more with methamphetamine mine is
more with opiates
she goes to bad psychosis trips
to where things aren't even real that
she's thinking of around her and she
would make up scenarios that aren't even
real at all in her head and she would
think that they are and
she's very very abusive
when she didn't get what you wanted and
she had a major spending problem with
money and she couldn't manage it
whatsoever
ultimately her abusiveness towards me
physically was the cause for me to leave
where I was at in Beaumont Texas to come
here until I I wanted to try something
new be around new people in a new start
to get away from that
because back home right before I left I
was addicted to spice synthetic
marijuana
and it was it was nasty it was a nasty
drug to do tastes nasty it looks nasty
and I just couldn't help and I I wanted
it and I craved it so much and so bad
that I told myself if I didn't figure
out something soon I was gonna die
one day a friend came up to me and said
hey I'll buy you a bus ticket to come to
LA with me let's do it and I said sure
why not [ __ ] what's the worst that could
happen
go to the guy there that I was going to
come out to that lady get addicted to
another drug substance it's just as bad
as the one I was already on
maybe worse
maybe worse yeah
um fentanyl yeah you go deep never
actually you've never did I've never
heard anything no thank God
the only reason is because of the years
of good abuse with previous pills and
heroin anything opiate related since I
had already been doing such massive
amounts my body was used to the the
feeling that I was going to get from the
Fentanyl no matter how much I've done it
I've actually tried to kill myself with
fentanyl in meth when it hot shot before
and it didn't work
I've tried to overdue myself and I can't
do it
it doesn't work for some reason only
something in my body that I have that
other people just don't I've seen many
people take just one little hit and just
die right in front of my eyes whereas I
can take hundreds of hits throughout the
day
and be perfectly fine and functioning
like I am now
I'm high right now but I'm a functioning
addict you wouldn't be able to tell
so
if you think there's a better chance
that you're gonna
get clean one day or
stay down here forever I hope there's a
better chance for me to get clean I want
to
I do know it's going to take me having
to move away from here completely
maybe back home because I haven't seen
my family in four years
my mom and dad they want to see me
really bad my brothers and sisters they
want to see me really bad
and here they have to be planning on
trying to make that [ __ ] within the next
month or so
[Applause]
I want to go definitely go out there to
go see them
and I think maybe if I do it might
benefit me in some way or help me to
where I can get off of this drug that
I'm on now and
just try and stay clean
you know
probably sometime next month I'm going
to end up going down there to go visit
them
would you say is your biggest regret
my biggest regret is just
not being able to say no
not being able to put the drugs down
definitely said that's that's the number
one regret
regret not being able to say no to drugs
like they always told us in school say
no to drugs kids
is there a shame that comes from all
this of course
I have so much Samus it's unreal the way
I feel
I don't even want my family to see me
like this
I regret it so much
I wish I could change it
Brandon what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
the most important lesson
is to learn how to say no to things that
are wrong
when you know deep down inside that
something's wrong you still say yes
you got to learn how to say no
especially when you know the difference
all right Brandon thank you so much for
sharing your story
you're welcome wish you the best of luck
out here thank you